what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg and John here to
watch The Witcher season three episode
two today as we wrap up Henry cavill's
last season of part one of his last
season John how are you I am Cav filled
with anticipation
filled anyway how are you better uh
ladies and gentlemen if you didn't catch
our episode one reaction that is up here
on the channel right now so please go
ahead toss a coin to the like button and
also subscribe click the notification
Bell get notified when our reaction for
the next episode is up on this channel
as always full length retro watch along
is resync with your own copy of The
Witcher available for our super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page cover
several things exclusively over there
with reaction highlights and watch Longs
included I want to say thank you to
everyone who's been joining our page uh
beginning so many pledges so far and uh
this means a lot it means it means
it's definitely a positive extension of
the real rejects let's get into action
people
thank you
foreign
[Music]
yes what's a mage doing all the way out
here she should be focusing on keeping
the Royal peace everyone noticed her
eyes looking like that though she can
Idol around me tonight
we keep their beauty by bathing in human
blood every night huh no no no that's
hearsay yeah you just have to go through
a magical ordeal to get the beauty good
speed Miss
it was just wishing you a safe journey
oh damn
never mind not a premonition flashback
she was kicked in head by a horse way to
keep it together
sir you're gonna be fine on this
fugitive Adventure I can't control my
vision you can control me stop calling
me like I'm a muelling brat I saw his
death and I need to go back there oh it
was a premonition everybody it's okay A
little bit of both because there was
definitely like old rants in there and
yeah I promise girls to keep you safe
we need something untraceable
maybe change her look we're going
shopping
we're going shopping or is he ask here
to do the Montage Music you don't have
any magic that can just slightly alter
your appearance yeah you would think how
much could their information possibly
cost to find her something Siri a lot
and why do we need that
oh cool special Witcher door you know I
had that safety device replaced just now
next time making that point now
roll those opening credits
now this will help get you what you
deserve
look at that balance you haven't fixed
the balance no [__] you told me to
she the one related to yeah oh God one
day I'll learn his name
[Laughter]
jeez drink
you want the White Flame to be poisoned
kind of well now
drink
I said drink
it's a good thing you're drunk would
hurt a lot more he is true he threatened
to get a friend of mine sorcerer's
rejects too often train as killers
Sorcerers rejects that sounds cool
that's when we're covering stuff like
this
yeah
any amount of coin I'm afraid that
information will cost you a bit more
geralt oh my God she knows how much it
is yeah let's try a wager I shot her my
back
you
shall throw this at my head
should you miss
you will give me the information that I
want on credit of course you'll still be
able to catch it though he didn't
stipulate the rules yeah
you didn't even Flinch why would I
flinch I heard you having to mess
having someone on a leash whose leash we
don't know we do know where this
sorcerer is doing his dirty business
there is a castle called volpan it's
near the old Scarlet how are my mind yes
great this time of year do you give our
best to the Elder blood princess
it's time to throw that star at her head
they know all you have a client looking
for her
damn it you want to save her you need to
find another girl an orphan of War
perhaps someone has to die so someone
else can live maybe you should die
series hair I will not pay for what I
love by having contempt for myself
bars Henry Cavill framed so well I know
cameras eats them up I don't want to put
you in Harm's Way Again
that's why I have to go to volpan I'll
come find you when Ryan's is dead well
he'll find me once you are
this guy is not gonna kill him
Carol's like you know it's not gonna
happen well
welcome home writing is rewriting
handmaiden and I are in need of one
foreign
no one counts
have a vision
[Music]
oh they open I won't be looking oh run
right
you have no idea
whoa
laughs
that is one of huvenago's men you don't
want to end up decapitated I suggest you
run too give a weight I think there was
a portal open Shoulda let her come
through the portal
mountainizing chaos
internet the alma mater we're wondering
why the kings are losing faith and it
was because we knew the elves were a
problem and we did nothing about it
returns risk the full test court and
let's get this rough patch smooth
loath as I am to admitted if you were to
return to court I am best placed here
with you
helping these girls learn what they're
capable of but I can't help but wonder
if it's really about them of course not
you are a bad teacher Tris
tell me about the L
ately
myself in different ways
what did you do it's foreplay I cannot
tell I think this is a role play
it's been useful
sadists
you almost give me perspective Clarity
or is this like their therapy
milfguard's not the only ones who know
it's ripe for the for the taking and if
radovid could be useful to us two retain
you
yeah those two detectives carteringer
and Fenn they know who riens is working
for I appreciate the information what I
really want is a song the audience wants
a song every season He Is Us
ah
now that was foreplay this season
sucks give me what I want Netflix I know
we'll get a song Eventually guys I'm
just joking
give me the noise
say we needed to avoid unwanted
attention you know all those lessons I
should have thought to you that
sometimes discretion is more important
than Valor no I don't know I had to do
work I chose to interfere dominicusan
Argo will send his cousin Leo bonhardt
here to recuperate his losses with money
with blood and then we're gonna get more
action scenes
you saved one
and the consequences likely damned a
hundred others in exchange what is the
point in me seeing the future if I can't
do anything to change it
looks cool that is a really great
question yeah why would you understand
you see what she wants you make it
happen how would you know what it's like
to fight for control of your life
if you'd seen my backstory man my ugly
one we're taking a detour
why do you call me that because I
promised I'd be sincere with you from
here forward I want to show you who I
really am
he's a hunchback oh goodness
oh
sword man Tahir gets a great return
ah
come on here
you'll pay for this Nils Guardian scum
whoa
some Evil Dead [__] right there get up
old friend
Francesca spells are nonsense about
prophecies so we don't die from hunger
and Frost and all you point these are
supposed to be superstitious who you
can't pointy apparently the princess is
the savior of Alvin Klein you've
considered my proposal
to take charge of the elves hi
you were a man's top General now I sent
you the raid Caravans on the ass end of
the battle lines why the hell is he
wasting God's giving Talent like yours
it's nice to see Robbie Amell like
someone yeah if I agree to your proposal
what does overthrower Francesca say
about my loyalty you will help him take
the north not Francesca he earned my
loyalty
I see you and yours damn I want these
two to be biting ship them
or that even better you're not a problem
with you Majors well you're too bloody
serious
man this is the best kind of jail though
oh [__] keep getting them drunk until
they're poisoned
I'm assume much I just skate once they
sent the dogs oh [__] the emperor only
absorbs you
that's your dad that's it she can figure
deaths probably yeah stop her heartbeat
we got another one
put them in the bag
you're nice to help me throw him out
Jesus
me keep your words on ice I'm listening
they say keep on playing ice but I have
no desire
songs are good man
[Music]
falsetto the greatest songs are made
of unspoken Words of Love
preach
with you I have enough with you I am
enough yes so in love with our Barton he
loves him he's so bored with life but he
feels when he asked gear sings
[Music]
not how he sings the emotion so well
it's been too long yaskir
I always wondered what it was that made
your song so resistible now I understand
come on you see people
for what they are not what they pretend
to be
my God kiss come on
I don't know yet
I'm determined to figure it out there's
like two vampires
I will dig around about this Rihanna's
character and his cohorts
yeah they have they're giving such and
rice right now I really like this guy a
lot yeah
sneaking mission
holy that was cool wow
[Music]
that is cool God that's like a Freddy
Krueger nightmare
squelching intensifies
are you all right oh no
are there any more like you here so many
more
growing decoys
what's his name Bria
always a sauce
oh
absolutely the centipede
oh no
all right
whatever I like this design a lot yeah
whoa jeez oh
it's sweet
it's such a nightmare
whoa It's like a Parry with so many
different arms yeah
[Music]
I love a good over the shoulders
that was just geralt button mashing the
whole time
wow
rest in peace
nobody checks any kind of bag in this
place I don't even check a pulse nope
he seems to think there's old farts Cod
Runner and fan might have some info
about re-ents perhaps I need to pay
those old farts a visit too
I said to him I'll give you a head start
but you argue an arrow in the bum now I
yell go he scuttles off like a wounded
deer and then I shot oh no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no
it's really hard it was gonna kill
something oh this guy damn
Philippa seems to think that you might
have more width than meets the eye
The Hope plays a fool yeah excuse me it
has no secrets from me and you do know
about his meeting last night
with MILF God
oh he's having fun sowing the seeds of
Chaos
nothing why am I even asking you're
going dead did they ever leave this room
I don't think they can you know who I
mean the witch was here I could still
smell the stench did you tell him we
didn't mention anything about your
employer what do you know about his
plans if you harm them
oh you gotta be [__] me nope it's
become everything
as long as a cat didn't die I'm okay I
sympathize with him now I'm rooting for
him we need to get the northern Kings to
listen to us and work together and the
last thing they want to see is the woman
who set their execution party in place
but you love her
God knows you won't fond of her that's
only because we have too much in common
the overwhelming name to win an argument
the love
for you yeah that was a little different
the end's more like my daughter
if yennefer can let go of the past
so can I and everybody else ah I've seen
Vanderpump Rules
grudges will be held
how much of a pig how much for this
piece don't you dare take your eyes off
me
I forgot how heartbreaking it was
watching that episode yeah thank you I
once chose to interfere I set a prisoner
free and in doing so I set the entire
knowledge against the Brotherhood
bodies hanging at the tavern
your fault it's not enough to possess
chaos
we must learn to control it that is the
essence of power
how we will move mountains
South hello
you're out of that place now
you're safe I knew you
and how would you know that a vision who
are you
don't be silly girl
you know who I am I'm Siri
why did you say that name
so yeah I was weird obviously she's
supposed to look like Siri
the whole time though I was sitting
there going like is that the actress's
sister or something like the actress who
plays Siri
Allen or whatever oh interesting
timelines are only gonna get more
confusing yeah
yeah all right well I like that more
than last episode yeah I did too looked
at a lot more in the last episode for
sure yeah I was back to more of what I
wanted it to be watch our opinions
become even more out of the general
public I know it was like people thought
the first one was the best I don't know
what this means for me yeah yeah I
really like this one a lot
um
you you start start John start yes sir
uh no yeah this breathed like this
season thus far has certainly a more
modern sensibility about its dialogue
but I thought this episode in terms of
pace in terms of what we focused on in
terms of the uh momentum with which
we're developing things felt a little
more natural a little more breathable
and it felt a little bit more like
inhabiting you know this fantastic goal
you know a medievalesque world in a more
I don't know sensory kind of way like
like the last episode was like oh we're
hopping around we're doing a bunch of
stuff and it feels like a Hollywood
movie sort of whereas this was like okay
I can feel the scope and the breadth of
the map and and all these different
places that we're in and I think
breaking the characters up again as much
as it is like fun to have them together
uh you know I think it certainly helps
just the spatial and the temporal
geography of the show
um so yeah I mean like I enjoyed
especially
I mean it's always fun to watch girl
kick ass but I especially enjoyed the
the kind of back and forth between Siri
and yennefer and the ways that you know
is allowed to I feel like in the
previous episode again we were talking
about like ah it doesn't seem like these
moments are allowed to be like earned by
the process of really living in them
whereas here yeah I I could really see
Siri's perspective of like I've got
these abilities I want to intervene
because that is what's right and then
yeah I thought that was a great time for
Jennifer to kind of bring back that bit
of context both of where she came from
because obviously Siri views her as
somebody who just has power already uh
innately and yeah then tying that back
around to the more not the present but
the more recent past with everything
with her and kahir and everything yeah I
just thought that yeah like it it felt
like it was calling upon its Tome of
details and it's you know
scope of world in a way that felt yeah
more akin to what I've been enjoying
thus far about the first couple of
seasons
um
these are all great thoughts John thanks
happy to hear that thank you
oh it's always good to get uh the the
couple back
prince's name right yeah okay all right
that's the character yeah I'm really
liking a lot Prince rad David I mean I
like the inclusion right now of red vid
raid ratavid and
um Gallatin uh Robia Mel's Elf character
yes the realistic Alpha the one who
doesn't succumb to folk tales fairy
tales and all that [__] yeah it's
about science and climate change you
know
[Laughter]
in Congo
I like it I know I like his presence a
lot he's a really cool elf and uh yeah
he's a really he's really fun to watch
and so far I mean a lot of it is still
we're still in very much setup stages so
mainly what I just want to talk about is
the main takeaways of things as I feel
like uh sure we can like sort of hop
around every little thing we checked in
on
um but I thought every character we
checked in on I enjoyed every scene that
we got this time around yeah uh right
down to even the goddamn names on this
show are just not my thing what is the
guy who's also at House of the Dragon
who's getting whipped dixtra I like what
they're doing with him because he was
just stoic
um you know spy before and now he's got
like a real personality and you really
see some Bare Bones Humanity to him join
that the rienne's character sure makes
me like him uh dislike him as a villain
when we're trying to say dislike him in
the right way as a villain by who he
killed in this episode a tad bit more
sure
um
Stills like the the mystery the
every season sort of built around some
type of mystery in some capacity and
right now that mystery is not like very
strong but the immediate moment of
watching the show has been very
enjoyable like the monster that we got
this time you gotta have an action scene
with geralt every episode I suppose in
the monster that he fought was a really
neat design I liked how those like heads
were totally like science fiction kind
of monster heads were Tethered to this
creature it kind of reminds me of like
when you fight like a multiple head
dragon in a way well yeah and it's like
the perfect distraction because it's
like the heads are there to throw you
off and to like make you doubt and the
body is just gonna collaborate you yeah
such a great design screaming the pain
of the centipede bodies it was really
cool it was a really cool design and I I
am
enjoying the uh they they said it about
a different character here but it is a
word that is applied
um
aptly for Siri as well impetuous the
impetuous side of Siri
because yes you can make some decisions
that go but then you're like but it
makes sense why you're doing that you
know I at least you're doing it for just
causes just purposes and we're really
building something right we're building
two windows
yeah I mean they teased that at the end
of last season yeah because right now it
is the hunt for Syria that's the that's
the main focus here and I like how
they're trying to go to
oh my God help me out John uh teratuza
is trying to go to aratuza yeah for
that's that's where you know
um Jennifer feels like that is the
safety spot for it but we know there's
also danger looming for Siri there like
no matter where she goes it is funny
enough the prince in last episode saying
that this is the least bad spot for her
is kind of like the only decisions that
yeah Siri is sort of left with yeah you
know
um and I like that geralt is a lot more
soft when speaking with certain
characters here write down his
relationship with the askier uh but I
feel like
there's a chance of things being frayed
when he finds out what yaskir has really
been up to when he asked you've really
been doing but the the bond that the
prince has with the asker I think is a
really interesting one there's
definitely some homo erotic thing going
on over there oh yeah and I hope it does
pan out in that direction that would be
a lot of fun to watch you could see it
on you ask your side that he's more than
likely a bisexual so I would be down for
it
um so right down to the prince as well
sure yeah sure let it happening I don't
know what their label is all right I'm
just saying they probably swing both
ways uh let it yes
go for it let it happen yeah and
yes the witches will rise certainly and
uh I mean that seems like all the big
stuff I mean you know there's you know
you got Tris back there eritus that
having her conflicts we saw vilga Fords
for a second he's cool uh
uh we got to see a dwarf lady make a
sword yeah yeah what's that guy's name
dwarf guy Witcher
is that Zoltan
all right I thought it was something
else
there you go yarp so maybe that is one
of his distant relations I like the the
woman who plays uh by the IMDb I'm going
with Philippa uh who is who's like a lot
with Dexter this season like I feel like
her inclusion has helped
I mean she's an interesting character
she's a good actor and also now Deeks
was more interesting as a byproduct of
that which is nice and uh and yeah it
was nice to get geralt just like off on
his own doing a doing a hunt and it
makes me wonder if maybe again not
knowing the source of material if
they're gonna mess with time where we
are in the timeline again because I mean
they could easily go girl it went off
but also he's in the past or also this
is like a prior thing or something I
don't know it feels of the present but
also that whole thing with like I'm Siri
feels like it could be some weird
I don't know intermingling of points in
time
or it's the Multiverse or it's the
Multiverse I hope this gets a Multiverse
not enough multiverses these days and
then season five we'll have Liam
Hemsworth and Henry Cavill yes oh
perfect and then we can get Chris
Hemsworth to play to play geralt as well
and Ben Affleck can play geralt
I can see all them playing different
versions of camera
he does move just the way he moves
though I don't know there's something
about Henry County I I always find
myself
remembering and appreciating in this
show in particular
because in Superman it like it's kind of
easy to overlook in some ways because
there's so many effects but here I'm
like yeah man it seems like he really
gets in there with the stunts and and
you know and the choreography and they
do a lot to make it apparent that it's
him yeah or or if not that's a great
Stitch job on the CG face but I have no
idea what to make of that ending me
neither it's really confusing sure
reincarnation thingy yeah hop in between
I mean obviously with Siri being able to
hop between the past and the future
some type of mine
's plant yeah thingy cloning facility
that's it it's actually there will be a
Twist it's the present day and series
just got a stage of the art cloning
facility
this is growing serious Nokes
I don't know I don't know the show is
designed to be binged so sure good
episode I'll say this one was a solid
installment I know we don't talk for I'm
not talking for too long this time
around we're trying to just get through
the these five yeah have a longer
discussion by the time we wrap up for
the fifth episode but so far
um I this was a uh more of an upswing
for for myself like I marked improvement
wasn't as much in love with the first
episode because it seems like everyone
in our comment box
really out of touch here
this will be good this is our Redemption
Journey Through the watch that be like I
don't know after first episode went down
but yeah this was this is definitely
better to me and um oh yeah yeah okay
there's a thing I need Clarity on uh oh
yeah ask your song short but again
there's something very effective about
every one of his songs no matter what
they are there's something very
effective about them I want the whole
album of the ask yours Tunes I do too
the the the thing with the
the little boy who was saved and they
said who was coming after him yes what
the hell's uh who what I was like
they clarified uh how that thing was set
up with the ask gear at the end of
season two and I was like oh yeah yeah
sorry it's been a while since I've seen
the show oh there's a lot of a lot of
room every every season requires a full
rewatch or two no it really does that
was that was something I was thinking of
about and then and then I'll yeah like
it seemed like the part of the way
they're writing this season is sort of
acknowledging that like uh you might not
have just watched this because it's been
a long time yeah like you know obviously
you want all that fresh in your mind uh
in the moment I mean I I was mostly
latched onto that just as an
illustration of yennefer's point but
yeah I mean if that hearkens back to
to the end of season two if he's
involved with that bigger picture then
that's a
that's a wrinkle I'm gonna have to
refresh myself on yeah I don't remember
yeah that's kind of confusing no yeah I
thought it was just like ah you know you
don't you didn't just freeze some random
kid like ah now they're gonna be like
you know
officials are gonna hear about this and
send people yeah
um but I I also like getting a reminder
of where Jennifer's come from and how
she would be the perfect proponent to
guiding Siri yeah or how far she's come
that way I mean that was such a vivid
part of her performance and I really
loved that version like as much as like
of course you want her to you know be in
her full like range of power and
capability like there was just something
very and physically hot yeah of course
gotta be hot that's the thing is like
you know I would never sacrifice the
hotness but the drama
almost worth it
um and yeah it's like you don't get any
new newly shot scenes that way but I do
like having it be sort of a reminder
because it was such a vivid and such a
unique thing about that first season and
so I feel like
I don't know she doesn't need that to be
interesting but I do feel like it's a
it's a distinct part of the character
that is worth not losing yeah yeah
alrighty well episode two down
three more to go Hells yeah I'm excited
benjamal right now
this minute I'm okay let's read a book
in an hour
all right but before we head out let's
do it
Lord Brandon of house Benzie my dude
listen I want to join your house all
right what's your sigil you know I feel
like we should figure it out right here
right now uh yes I think it should be
the three fingers and a hand and a
finger going through yeah that's what it
is yeah it's a symbol of synergy it's a
symbol of you know it's it's things are
okay and that's where we're going is
towards worth okay okay
the Brandon Benzie house
together they form kind of like a six
and a nine upside down sure
yeah yeah yeah you put the two humps you
put the one hump in between the other
hump and the other hump yeah it's like
it's like a 69 for two perfect butt
cheeks
totally yeah yeah two two B's for two
butts for for so there's many different
schedules we just went through all three
seasons oh yeah yeah and season one and
then he was like a six and a nine and
it's season three is like two bees
touching each other like two butts yeah
but it's not actually sexual YouTube no
no no yeah and then the third and then
the final one is like it's it's it's
kind of like the 69 formation but you're
just hugging each other's tummies yeah
yeah totally that's the BB way
and these are all deciduals of all the
different episodes of your season so uh
you know we'll smelt them in pewter and
we'll send them to you as a special
token of our gratitude but Brandon
Benzie would be honored to uh you know
to fly your flag at my house and uh yeah
stay pledged you know toss that coin bag
we won't count it and we'll see you next
month love you buddy love you buddy
[Music]